i think something very big is coming up
with ufc a fight
very big versus boxers no no no no no
i'm talking purely ufc i think okay i
think dana's up to something and he's
about to launch a very big fight but the
boxers just take everything from him
because
well hey he runs the whole you know if
it wasn't for him
i mean my god boxing would be dead
there'd be no ufc but i think he could
flip over if it weren't for
dana white dana white and if he's one
for him boxing would be dead
no if it wasn't for dana white we'd have
no
combat sports daniel white's helped out
boxing and ufc
how has he helped out boxing are you
kidding me what happened with the with
the counter fight against mayweather
what happens to a lot of these boxing
fights
did he arrange that that was his deal he
didn't arrange that but if he didn't
create a platform where he promotes the
way he did to
to give birth to conor mcgregor who goes
from being on welfare to not being worth
a few hundred million dollars
to being one of the biggest box office
fights hey that credit goes to the
promoter big part of the credit goes to
the promoter and that's dana white
clearly um he's dominated with the ufc i
just didn't understand the
the how it carries over to boxing you're
saying a rising tide lifts all ships
he's lifting those boxes if you ask me
yeah i think he's helped because it's a
rising sh you know the whole rising
right
tide left all the ships but i tell you
they're dominating right now yeah
there's a nobel
i have i have not ordered a fight in a
long time
a fight like meaning boxing if i do it
have to be a big one i don't order the
boxing fights
ufc's it's like a regular thing i think
it's this
as ridiculous as it sounds i think it's
the paul brothers that are actually
making boxing relevant again
since floyd retired what does that tell
you though what is that
there needs to be some some some action
on the boxing ring
there needs to be a don king coming in
the mix like a dana white
to make boxing excited again dana white
is the face of ufc yeah
who's the face of boxing good luck
finding a dana white oscar de la hoya
tried to do it oscar's not dana white
to be a promoter it's not everybody's
job i once interviewed wayne demilia one
of the greatest bodybuilding promoters
of all time this guy would show up in a
camel
to with he would bring a bodybuilder on
a camel
in a show just because he wanted to he
was a massive promoter
you can every industry every sport that
ever did great
you will find a great promoter behind
closed doors wwe every single mcmahon
every single game had a great promoter
dana happens to be one of the best if
not the best of all so why can't they
figure it out in boxing
like corruption is it it's been just a
corrupt sport and uh
political they don't know how to promote
it here's the other thing
i mean dana white is so powerful so
influential right now he's the main
reason i think that endeavor william
morris was able to get their ipo
because they brought in the private
investors to totally bring the
the ufc into the fold and that allowed
them to go public after failing in 2019
and it's the most valuable commodity
with with endeavor and william morris
gonna the stock started at 24 it's
moving its way up that thing's only
getting bigger but you know what
jake paul has started a dialogue that
the box or that the ufc fighters are
underpaid
and it's going to be a huge thorn in
dana white's side
follow this he went off on it the other
night he's like the champion for ufc
fighters saying you're the ones putting
your life on the line
risking your health and your injuries
and you're not getting paid you know
that's pissing off dana white big time
that's nothing new though that's been
said for a long time that's been that's
been said about dana for 15 years but
he's got a big bullhorn and people are
actually hearing it because jake paul's
got a following
yeah i i by the way i agree with you i
think there's things going on over there
where he's not paying the guys as much
as they are to him his opinion is more
from the place of
at least these guys were making nothing
now they're making this they were they
were coming off the streets and they're
not professional boxers they're street
fighters now they're making this
but i do think that can hurt him long
term i just i just think it's a story
that he's been able to deflect for a
very long time
well it's like you're believing the
power of competition if you have who's
ufc's competitor bellator is it bellator
i don't even never even heard of that
that's my point is i've never ordered
so if so if someone if a conor mcgregor
or khabib or you pick a name cormier
whoever
he's like i don't know i'm done with
this you're not paying me no go
ahead i'm going to bellator
all right good luck at bellator buddy
i've never even heard of it see what
kind of a show
that's the problem with competition is
that yeah they might be paying their
fighters
less than market value but the market
creates the value if there's no place to
go
i'm with dana white it's the sport that
is the number one it's the
it's the spectacle it's the show jake
paul said one of the ring girls was
actually paid more than one of the
fighters
on the last card see that's the kind of
the thing she must have been hot though
the thing with jake paul the thing with
jake paul is that he's a professional
troll
he's a professional troll he's even a
better troll than his brother is logan's
not a troll
jake is a troll true jake i would say
jacob's heroes probably
probably takashi 69 maybe trump if i
were to tell you
who jake models his game after it has to
be takashi 69
not even trump it has to be takata he
faced time with trump no
he did i know but what i'm trying to
tell you with the comments tips trump
was a billionaire trolling people he was
at the top trolling people
takashi came from nowhere to being
everybody says i can't believe this
guy's alive this guy's alive
how is takashi still alive going out
there saying what he's saying right the
other day
he posted something on instagram saying
here's a gofundme account for this guy
go help him
buy little you know uh lemon because he
needs a card
he's a professional and he literally
looks like a troll and and
jake is duplicating what does that have
what are the long-term consequences of
being a freaking troll
like short-term yeah people you're on
the news you get rich
you're you're in the news okay let me
ask you guys long-term you're gonna be
the most
go back who are the biggest trolls and
how how did it turn out for them
how did it turn out well if it's takashi
six nine you do a little time in jail
no no no what i'm saying is go back okay
go back to the 70s 80s
so for example morton downey jr was one
of the biggest trolls okay
pull up his uh okay in the 80s and early
90s i don't know what the exact year was
morton downey jr for 18 months took over
jerry took over montel williams took
over oprah winfrey
took over everybody he was it he would
smoke
cigarettes get in people's faces curse
him out on national television
and he brought ron paul he brought
everybody on morton downey jr kai
can you pull that up something something
that comes to mind is uh
uh charlie sheen when his tiger blood
days of the early 2000's when he's i
think that's drugs though that's that's
okay but he was trolling people whether
you're on drugs or not
that's more
is your point here ultimately it doesn't
last long i
i don't know that's what i'm trying to
find out with you by the way you know
what happened to them the challenge with
trolls is the following here's a
challenge with trolls
eventually if you have nothing of
substance to show for it the audience
goes for the next
troll trolls are seasonal people leave
you
in a heartbeat if you have nothing new
to troll so for example
if there's nothing new for jake paul to
troll what's going to happen now if he
can
last it for five ten years and produce a
few hundred million followers
he is a very relevant person at 35 now
he's got a family he's got maybe living
a different life he may have a different
opinion the whole story with these
trolls
is if you win or not meaning if takashi
69 comes out and has a banger album
and he's the number one on the charts
that actually makes good music all right
it's hard to argue against that
if jake paul actually goes 4-0 5-0 10-0
but once his ass gets knocked down he's
irrelevant
control true sure i wouldn't say he was
a
troll i think he was i think he ruffled
some feathers and he was just a straight
guy
so let's define what a troll is what is
a troll i don't know what to do an
instigator
you know again what is a troll i think
there's two types of trolls i think
there's the troll that actually
is is kind of has some beef and that
they're they're putting out there and
they it's
like tupac and then there's a troll
that's in harmony oh
i mean the best we're not against rap
well we are against
rappers he called out pushing against
the i guess my point is you're pushing
against the system you have a point to
make you actually do have some substance
some value
versus just being a talker annoying
troll
just for the point of being annoying
that's what i think jake paul is
you think jake paul is annoying is what
you're saying i think the the stat show
he's probably the most hated man in
america right now
we can ask ask our audience but now what
you're saying is jake paul is an
annoying troll
that's what you're saying but he's still
a troll and once he gets his ass knocked
out and loses let me ask you a question
you tell me you tell me a troll in the
history of trolls
that didn't annoy somebody that wasn't
annoying
to somebody so they're part of their dna
but jake paul happens to be
your annoying troll not mine i don't you
he obviously
tells me america's by his office in his
desk
tell him can i tell the truth about
adam's computer here it is what
okay when adam next to the notebook when
it goes what do you call it when the
computer screen uh uh
starts screen saver screen saver jake
paul's picture he's got uh
i don't understand why you do that to
yourself i know he wants to fight him
you know jake paul has monetized his
trolling that's that's
what he's been able to do in the big
time give him respect on that and you
see i disagree i don't think he has to
win his fights because
he's smart enough to always pick a fight
with the baddest dude on the block
so he's not trolling wimps he's the
baddest dude on the block floyd
mayweather
uh conor mcgregor but he hasn't fought
these people yeah but he's trolling them
he's instigating it he's doing it right
now he's getting the attention
plus i will say this the dude is
influential i'm not a huge fan
but i know the influence he has because
i drove to his house probably eight
times because dash was a fan of him
four or five years ago when he was
cranking up videos and we had to go to
work
he's better role models
better role models so if you enjoy this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye